"¿Por qué algunas personas son racistas?",
Y otra estudiante, llamémosla Abby,
alzó su mano y respondió:
"Tal vez no les gusten los negros porque su piel es del color de la caca".
Sí, lo sé.
Como si estuvieran de acuerdo, la clase entera estalló.
La mitad empezó a reír de inmediato,
y la otra mitad empezó a chillar a Abby
y gritar cosas como:
"¡Oh, Dios mío, no puedes decir eso, es racista!".
Tomen un momento para fijar esta escena en su mente.
Una clase de niños de 9 a 10 años,
y la mitad de ellos histéricos
porque piensan que lo que dijo Abby es algo muy divertido
y la otra mitad chillándole por decir algo ofensivo.
Y luego tienen a Abby, sentada ahí completamente perpleja
porque en su mente, no entendía el peso de lo que había dicho
y por qué todos reaccionaban de esa manera.
Y luego me tienen a mí, la profesora
de pie en la esquina, a punto de tener un ataque de pánico.
Como profesora de la clase,
tengo que tomar decisiones contrarreloj todo el tiempo.
Y supe que tenía que reaccionar, pero ¿cómo?
Consideren sus instintos de lucha o huida.
Podía luchar elevando mi voz y reprendiéndola por sus palabras.
O huir: solo cambiar de tema
y empezar rápido con otro tema,
cualquier cosa para que se olvidaran de la palabra "caca".
Sin embargo, como sabemos, lo correcto es a menudo lo más difícil de hacer.
Y por mucho que quisiera que este momento terminara,
y que sabía que ambas opciones me ayudarían a escapar de la situación,
supe que era un momento de aprendizaje muy importante.
Después de estar ahí por lo que sentí una eternidad,
me desbloqueé y me volví para enfrentar a la clase, y dije:
"De hecho, Abby tiene razón".
Y mis estudiantes se miraron unos a otros, confundidos.
Y continué:
"Una razón por la que el racismo existe
es porque personas de piel blanca miraron a personas de piel oscura
y dijeron que su piel era desagradable".
E incluso usan esta razón como excusa para deshumanizarlos.
Y la razón por la que aprendemos sobre raza y racismo en primer lugar
es educarnos para saber más.
Y entender por qué estos comentarios son hirientes,
y asegurar que las personas con piel oscura
sean siempre tratados con respeto y amabilidad".
Este fue un momento de aprendizaje realmente aterrador.
Pero a medida que avanzamos en la conversación
noté que tanto Abby, como el resto de los chicos,
estaban deseando entender.
Y mientras veía la conversación calando en mis estudiantes,
comencé a preguntarme cuántos de mis estudiantes tienen prejuicios como Abby.
¿Y qué pasa cuando esas prejuicios pasan desapercibidos y sin abordar
como a menudo ocurre?
Pero primero, es importante dar un paso atrás
e incluso pensar sobre lo que convierte algo en tema tabú.
No recuerdo haber recibido una lista oficial de cosas
de las que no se puede hablar.
Pero recuerdo oír de niña una y otra vez:
hay dos cosas de las que no se habla en reuniones familiares.
Y esas dos cosas son la religión y la política.
Y siempre pensé que eso era muy curioso
porque la religión y la política a menudo son grandes factores de influencia
sobre muchas de nuestras identidades y creencias.
Pero lo que hace a un tema tabú
es el sentimiento de incomodidad que surge al conversar sobre estas cosas.
Pero algunas personas son extremadamente fluidas en el lenguaje de la igualdad,
mientras otras temen no ser políticamente correctas
o que su ignorancia se muestre tan pronto como abran la boca.
Pero creo que el primer paso para mantener conversaciones
sobre cosas como igualdad
es empezar a construir un lenguaje común.
Y que empieza con desestigmatizar temas
que normalmente son considerados tabú.
Bien, las conversaciones sobre la raza, por ejemplo,
tienen su lenguaje específico propio
y los estudiantes deben hablar fluidamente este lenguaje
para tener estas conversaciones.
Las escuelas suelen ser el único lugar
donde los estudiantes puedan sentirse libres y cómodos
para hacer preguntas y cometer errores.
Pero, por desgracia, no todos los estudiantes sienten esa seguridad.
Supe ese día delante de mis estudiantes
que cómo eligiera responder podría tener implicaciones de por vida
no solo para Abby, sino para el resto de estudiantes en mi clase.
Si hubiera dejado de lado sus palabras,
el resto de la clase podría haber deducido que este tipo de comentarios es aceptable.
Pero si le hubiera gritado a Abby
y la hubiera avergonzado delante de sus amigos,
ese sentimiento de vergüenza asociado a su primera conversación sobre la raza
podría haber impedido involucrarse en ese tema nuevamente.
Enseñar a los niños sobre igualdad en las escuelas no es enseñarles qué pensar.
Es darles las herramientas y estrategias y lenguaje
y oportunidades para practicar cómo pensar.
Por ejemplo, piensen en cómo enseñamos a los niños a leer.
No empezamos dándoles libros.
Comenzamos dividiendo las palabras en letras y sonidos
y los animamos a practicar su fluidez leyendo cada día,
con un compañero o sus amigos.
Y les damos montones de preguntas de comprensión
para asegurarnos de que están entendiendo lo qué están leyendo.
Y creo que enseñar a los niños sobre la igualdad
debe ser abordado de la misma manera.
Me gusta comenzar dando a mis estudiantes una encuesta cada año,
sobre diferentes temas sobre igualdad e inclusión.
Este es un ejemplo de encuesta de uno de mis niños,
y como puede ver, hay humor aquí.
Bajo la pregunta: "¿Qué es 'race' [raza o carrera]?"
escribió: "Cuando dos o más autos, gente o animales
corren para ver cuál es más rápido y cuál gana".
Sin embargo, si miran su pregunta: "¿Qué es el racismo?"
dice: "Cuando alguien dice o llama a alguien de piel oscura un nombre malo".
Ella es joven, pero está mostrando que empieza a comprenderlo.
Y cuando actuamos
como si nuestros estudiantes no fueran capaces de tener estas conversaciones
en realidad les hacemos un perjuicio.
También sé que este tipo de conversaciones
pueden ser muy, muy intimidantes para nuestros estudiantes,
especialmente con estudiantes jóvenes.
Pero he enseñado de primer a quinto grado,
y puedo decirles, por ejemplo,
que no voy a entrar en la clase de primer grado
y empezar a hablar de cosas como el encarcelamiento masivo.
Pero incluso un chico de 6 años de primer grado puede entender la diferencia
entre lo que es justo... gente que tiene lo que necesita.
Identificamos un montón de cosas en clase juntos.
Y la diferencia entre lo justo y lo igual...
cuando todos tienen lo mismo,
especialmente bolsas de regalos en cumpleaños.
Bien, los de primer grado pueden también entender la diferencia
entre un castigo y una consecuencia.
Y todas estas cosas son conceptos fundamentales
que todos deben comprender
antes de tener una conversación
sobre la encarcelación masiva en EE. UU.
Algunos pueden pensar que los niños de kínder o primer grado
son muy jóvenes para tener conversaciones sobre racismo,
pero también les digo que los niños pequeños
entienden que hay muchos componentes diferentes
que conforman nuestras identidades
y cómo las personas son similares y diferentes,
y qué significa tener poder cuando hay otros que no lo tienen.
Cuando tenemos esas conversaciones con estudiantes jóvenes,
en realidad se quita algo del sentimiento de tabú
cuando esos temas surjan a una edad posterior.
También sé que enseñar estas cosas en las escuelas
puede ser como atravesar un campo de minas.
Por ejemplo, ¿qué pasa si hay padres o familias
que no están de acuerdo con tener estas conversaciones en las escuelas?
Pero a esas personas, puedo decirles:
estos son algunos ejemplos de cosas que los estudiantes me han dicho
y me llamaron la atención.
Por ejemplo, tuve un estudiante que vino y me susurró:
"He escuchado a toda la gente usar el término LGTBQ,
pero no sé qué significa y me da mucha vergüenza admitirlo".
Tuve un estudiante que vino tras el fin de semana y me dijo:
"Sabes, acabo de ver esta película sobre Australia,
y me hizo preguntarme si tienen racismo allí también".
Y siempre quiero que mis estudiantes estén cómodos con estas conversaciones
porque cuando están cómodos hablando sobre ello y haciendo preguntas,
también construyen comodidad, la llevan a sus vidas y experiencias
sobre cómo se relacionan con estos grandes temas.
También, algunos profesores podrían sentirse incómodos
si un alumno saca un tema o hace una pregunta
y no saben la respuesta.
Pero si un estudiante llama mi atención
y yo no sé la respuesta,
lo admitiré y lo tendré en cuenta
porque no voy a pretender que soy una experta en algo
en lo que no tengo experiencia o en lo que no soy una autoridad.
Ese mismo año, tuve un estudiante que vino
y me hizo una pregunta sobre la comunidad LGBTQ.
Y yo no sabía lo suficiente para darle una respuesta adecuada.
Así que en cambio, animé al estudiante
a contactar y hacer esa pregunta a un representante de una organización
que había venido a hablar a nuestra clase sobre el mismo tema.
Cuando admitimos a nuestros estudiantes no tener todas las respuestas
no solo nos humaniza frente a ellos,
les muestra que los adultos tenemos un largo camino por delante, también,
cuando supone aprender sobre temas de igualdad.
Hace poco escribí una lección sobre consentimiento.
Y para algunos, esto fue muy emocionante
porque tomé este tema que parecía muy tabú y aterrador
y lo desglosé de forma accesible para los estudiantes jóvenes.
Sin embargo, para otras personas,
la idea del consentimiento está fuertemente ligada al sexo,
y el sexo es a menudo considerado un tema tabú,
y los puso muy incómodos.
Pero mi estudiantes son de tercer grado,
así que no hablamos de sexo en clase.
Más bien, quería que entendieran
que todo el mundo tiene diferentes límites físicos
que los hacen sentirse incómdos.
Y la inteligencia social y emocional que conlleva
entender las palabras de alguien, su tono y lenguaje corporal
son habilidades que deben ser enseñadas explícitamente,
igual que enseñamos lectura y matemáticas.
Y esta lección no está reservada a estudiantes de un solo grupo demográfico.
Cosas como cuestionar y hacer observaciones
y el pensamiento crítico
son cosas que cualquier estudiante de cualquier raza o etnia
u origen, o lenguaje, o ingresos o código postal, debería aprender en la escuela.
Además, evitar deliberadamente estas conversaciones
dice mucho a nuestros estudiantes
porque los niños notan cuando sus profesores, sus libros de texto
dejan de lado las voces y experiencias de mujeres o gente de color.
El silencio dice mucho.
Hace poco pregunté a mi clase de tercer grado
qué le dirían a los adultos que piensan que son muy jóvenes
para aprender sobre temas de igualdad.
Y si bien esta es una pequeña muestra de mis 25 estudiantes,
todos estuvieron de acuerdo
en que no solo son capaces de tener estas conversaciones,
sino que ven el derecho de aprenderlo, como un derecho y no un privilegio.
Y, en sus palabras:
"Somos suficientemente grandes para saber sobre esas cosas
porque estos problemas están pasando donde vivimos.
Y tenemos el derecho de hablar sobre ellas
porque serán nuestra vida en el futuro".
Gracias
(Aplausos)